es ist ein Heimspiel für tenochrophaler
an diesem Mittwoch im 4000 Seelen
Örtchen Boxberg in Sachsen Heimspiel im
doppelten Sinne Boxberg liegt im
Wahlkreis des afd-chefs und hier in der
Dorfkneipe geht es heute um eines der
Kernthemen seiner Partei um Flüchtlinge
rund 50 hat Boxberg aufgenommen gegen
ihrer allerwen dagegen so lautet das
Prinzip AFD
wir haben Alleinstellungsmerkmale wir
vertreten die Interessen der Bürger also
wir haben keine Werte geleitete Politik
sondern interessengeleitete Politik wir
stellen uns klar gegen die
Wirtschaftssanktionen gegen Russland
aber auch die zukünftigen Sanktionen die
schon gegen China geplant sind und wir
sind das Gegenbeispiel der Grünen Partei
das nur die AFD die Interessen der
Bürger vertritt und die anderen Parteien
nicht das ist die Erzählung der AFD das
immer mehr sich vorstellen können sie zu
wählen das aber ist ein Fakt die AFD
fährt ein Umfrage hoch nach dem anderen
ein in einer ARD-Umfrage liegt sie in
dieser Woche erstmals gleich auf mit der
SPD der Partei des Kanzlers
der spielt das Phänomen herunter wir
leben in einer Zeit der Umbrüche bei der
ganz viele Bürgerinnen und Bürger in
unseren Ländern nicht so sicher sind ob
die Zukunft auf ihrer Seite ist ob sie
eine haben aber wenn wir tapfer ein
Problem nach dem anderen lösen und die
Zukunftsfrage und die respektsfrage
nicht vergessen dann wird schon gelingen
Prinzip Hoffnung damit kommt der Kanzler
nicht mal in seiner eigenen Partei bei
allen durch das dann wird schon gelingen
würde ich nicht in dem Optimismus Teilen
wie wir kommuniziert haben
Streitigkeiten die nicht sein hätten
müssen oder die komisch geführt wurden
ich glaube dass wir da besser auf dem
Platz sein müssen mehr diskutieren
müssen und dass wir einfach auch uns
selbst hinterfragen müssen als SPD die
SPD streitet und die Ampel streitet seit
Monaten die AFD steigt auf auch seit
Monaten erster Sprung Sommer 22 die
Regierung zockt sich wegen der gasumlage
und auch die Atomfrage sorgt für heftige
Debatten sowie die steigende Inflation
der nächste Sprung gelingt der AFD
während sich die Ampel in 30 Stunden
koalitionsgipfelmarathon und in der
heizungsfrage beinahe zerlegt
der Zuwachs der AFD wenn ich das mal so
platt sagen darf korrespondiert mit dem
Abschmelzen der Grünen darüber würde ich
mir Gedanken machen die Ampel streitet
also weiter jetzt geht's um die
Schuldfrage Habeck sein heizungsgesetz
die Grünen wollen die Debatte nicht
führen ich glaube mit einfachen
Schuldzuweisungen es ist nicht getan
erstmal gilt für die AFD was für alle
Parteien gilt mit Umfragen gewinnt man
keine Wahlen sondern es gilt was am Ende
des Tages rauskommt nämlich bei den
Wahlen wenn sich die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger entscheiden müssen jedoch lassen
nicht nur die Umfragen die AFD vor
locken den ZDF liegen Mitgliederzahlen
vor und die steigen seit Beginn diesen
Jahres langsam aber kontinuierlich in
eine Partei einzutreten noch dazu in
eine die in Teilen vom Verfassungsschutz
als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft ist das ist ein sehr klares
Bekenntnis
und die Union im Kampf um den
Parteivorsitz war Friedrich Merz für
sich mit der Aussage die AFD zu
halbieren die stand dabei rund 15
Prozent dieser Plan ist also erstmal
gescheitert darüber hinaus gewinnt seine
CDU im Bund im Gegensatz zu AFD derzeit
keine Stimmen dazu in ostdeutschen
Ländern liegt sie sogar hinter der AFD
so auch in Sachsen dort will März
Parteikollege Michael Kretschmann
nächstes Jahr wieder Ministerpräsident
werden seine Strategie afd-themen
besetzen harte Forderungen formulieren
wie die nach einer Verschärfung des
Asylrechts im Zweifel durch Änderung des
Grundgesetzes
wir haben eine Sondersituation weil wir
bewusst gewollt und auch richtig so
Menschen aus Kriegsgebieten aus der
Ukraine in einer sehr großen Anzahl eine
Millionen unterstützen und deswegen
müssen wir hier handeln und nicht warten
bis die Situation nicht mehr
unter Kontrolle ist
rechts blinken oder klein reden so sieht
der Umgang der anderen Parteien mit der
AFD aus also alles beim Alten was neu
ist die Rekordwerte der AFD
und im Studio begrüße ich jetzt den
Generalsekretär der CDU guten Abend
ihr Parteivorsitzender hat auch hier
Ihnen eine Messlatte gesetzt er wollte
die AFD halbieren damals war sie bei
15%, das wären siebeneinhalb jetzt ist
sie bei 18 oder 19% heute man könnte das
Krachen gescheitert nennen
wir sehen diese Entwicklung auch mit
großer Sorge wir wussten immer dass es
ein rechtsextremistischen Kern gibt in
der Gesellschaft aber immer mehr
Menschen haben kein Vertrauen mehr in
die Institutionen in die Demokratie
haben den Eindruck dass ihre Sorgen
nicht im Mittelpunkt der politischen
Debatten stehen und nehmen uns auch in
Teilen noch in Verantwortung für Dinge
der Vergangenheit wenn ich
beispielsweise an die Frage der
Migrationspolitik denke dann sind das
Dinge in denen wir zwar heute schon
deutlich andere Vorschläge gemacht haben
und auch auf Parteitagen unter der
früheren Vorsitzenden zum Ausdruck
gebracht haben dass das Jahr 2015/16
sich so nicht noch mal wiederholen darf
aber nichtsdestotrotz das Vertrauen ist
noch nicht vollständig da wir müssen an
diesem Vertrauen arbeiten die Ursache
liegt natürlich im Streit dieser
Koalition und das kann von halbieren
sprechen und jetzt sehen dass es auf 18
19 geht ja unsere Aufgabe besteht darin
die Menschen zu erreichen und ihm zum
Ausdruck zu bringen dass wir die
politischen Alternativen haben dass
diese in der Mitte zu suchen sind und
nicht an den politischen Ränder dann die
Menschen haben Sorge vor den Dingen die
im Land geschehen und haben den Eindruck
dass das nicht im Mittelpunkt steht
Friedrich Merz hat gesagt dass eine
große Herausforderung er hat ja von
diesem Ziel auch gesagt das wird sehr
schwer werden weil es auch immer mehr
Menschen gibt die sich von der
Demokratie und von den Institutionen
abwenden wir arbeiten weiter daran diese
Menschen zu erreichen schauen wir noch
mal auf ihre Partei ich darf ihren
Parteifreund Norbert Röttger Röttgen
zitieren die Union solle sich selbst
kritisch fragen warum sie nicht
profitiert von einer so großen
Unzufriedenheit mit der Regierung können
sie es ihm beantworten wir sind stärkste
Kraft würde ich ihm zunächst sagen und
haben gezeigt dass unter der Führung von
Friedrich Merz ist gelungen ist die
Einigkeit zwischen CDU und CSU
herzustellen den inhaltliche
Neuaufstellung zu machen und natürlich
auch mit sehr vielen Initiativen im
Deutschen Bundestag die Probleme
anzusprechen
ja weil das narrativ wir sein
verantwortlich für die 16 Jahre obwohl
wir ja mit SPD und FDP regiert haben
sich einigermaßen gut hält und nicht
deutlich wird dass die Herausforderung
vor denen wir heute stehen dass wir dazu
sehr viele gute Vorschläge über 250 in
den Deutschen Bundestag eingebracht
haben zum Thema Inflation zum Thema
Gesundheitsversorgung zu der Frage ist
jetzt alles noch auf die Vergangenheit
nein das schiebe ich auf gar keinen Fall
auf die Vergangenheit sondern ich sage
es muss noch deutlicher werden dass wir
an diesen Themen arbeiten und das machen
wir deutlich in unserer Partei wir sind
bei 30 Prozent damit sind wir nicht
zufrieden aber es ist ein gutes Ergebnis
nach anderthalb Jahren schauen wir mal
nach vorne die nächsten Landtagswahlen
sind ja unter anderem auch im Osten im
nächsten Jahr da ist mitunter in einigen
Ländern die AFD jetzt schon stärkste
Partei ihr Parteifreund Kretschmer in
Sachsen hat vorgeschlagen das
Grundgesetz zu ändern um die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge zu begrenzen würden Sie das
teilen zunächst muss eine Menschen
deutlich sagen wir eine Politik der
Mitte will und dass sie Probleme gelöst
wird der muss seine Stimme bei der CDU
geben das haben wir bei den
Landratswahlen in Sachsen auch zum
Ausdruck gebracht und an allen
Meinungsumfragen lag die AFD ganz vorne
wir haben die Landratswahlen gewonnen
und die AFD profitiert davon das Land zu
spalten zu hetzen sie will die Probleme
nicht lösen Grundgesetzänderungen
Migration ja und Michael Kretschmer
spricht an sehr ernstes Thema an wir
haben mehr als eine Million ukrainische
Flüchtlinge aufgenommen und darüber
hinaus derzeitig 1.000 Flüchtlinge am
Tag 30.000 im Monat das ist deutlich zu
viel dann auch für eine
Grundgesetzänderung ich bin dafür dass
wir parteiübergreifend dieses Thema
diskutieren und es ist ein
Lösungsvorschlag der aus meiner Sicht
mit auf den Tisch gehört der hat ihre
Unterstützung ich finde der Vorschlag
ist der Rede wert es ist möglicherweise
ein Weg ich finde man muss auch diesen
Weg miteinander diskutieren bei der AFD
wird strategisch gedacht in Richtung
Duldung von möglichen
Minderheitsregierung hätte das ihre
Zustimmung nein für uns steht die
Brandmauer ganz klar wir werden mit
einer rechtsextremistischen Partei die
im Verfassungsschutzbericht auftaucht
die klar unter Sicht Antisemiten hat die
rechtsradikale hat die Menschen hat die
bei der reichsbürgerbewegung dabei waren
und die jetzt im Gefängnis aussetzen
weil sie in diesem Land einen Putsch
herbeiführen wollten wir werden mit
dieser Partei nicht koalieren nicht
zusammenarbeiten das sagen wir klar und
deutlicher das gilt in Ost und West und
Nord und Süd und sagen wir werben um die
Wählerinnen und Wähler die in Teilen
nicht der harte Kern der
rechtsextremistisch ist die in Teilen
derzeitig sagen sie könnten sich
vorstellen diese Partei zu wählen und
sie suchen auch bei uns die politische
Alternative die dieses Land wieder
vernünftig fühlen auf kommunaler Ebene
muss man sagen schon 18 mal diese
Brandenburger Risse bekommen hat nein
mit nichten wir haben auch auf der
kommunalen Ebene eine sehr klare Linie
dazu und wir haben auch dort immer die
Entscheidung getroffen die notwendig
sind mit uns gibt es keine
Zusammenarbeit mit der herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch